we're gonna get to the phones uh because
we got people got questions
tyler from denver how can we help you my
friend
hey chris hey john thanks for taking my
call um
so i'm on baby step two currently i've
been
dealing with that for about the past
four or five months my predicament i'm
in is i have a
fifth wheel trailer that i purchased new
in 2017
um that i was using for my job and i no
longer need
uh but it is my most sizable debt
file i think eighty seven thousand
dollars on that
goodness gracious that's a
fancy fifth wheel my man what does it do
87 okay hold on how much did you buy it
for
so that's the thing i i had owned a
trailer previously and as you know they
depreciate
like it's no tomorrow so i rolled you
know having not heard dave
oh i rolled the balance of my old one
uh into the new loan i got you
i got you i thought this is
i got into it for about 110 and 97.
okay what do you think this one is worth
uh so that's my kicker i could sell it
right now for somewhere between
40 and 50 000. goodness
okay um
which either way it's you're still
you're looking at a
at a 37 to 42 000 shortfall right
exactly and well i guess my question was
do i have
oh a personal loan and some fleece
as they would call it um that are the
two
before the trailer i didn't know if i
should continue to pay on it
even though it's depreciating um you
know and i don't have
the the difference sitting in my bank
account and
i know you know the talk is to not take
you out another loan
i'm just kind of stuck don't know how to
deal with it yeah tell me this
uh what what how much is the payment on
this fifth wheel
uh six hundred dollars a month okay and
what's the interest rate do you know
uh four percent okay 600 so is it
financed for like
111 years yeah i think it's i think it
took a 15-year
note on it yeah is this from through a
bank or a credit union
that's through a bank okay because your
rate is really low on it
are they they're holding the title on
this thing too correct
correct okay um all right talk to me at
the lease what do you
what what is this what size truck did
you get to pull this thing
well no so i you know i started i've
sold my dually truck that i had
and i took out a lease on a little f-150
you know for the wife and the kid
what have you um so i'm i think i owe
another two years on that before it's up
um
and then i have a you know twelve
thousand dollar personal loan
that i'm almost gotten taken care of
what was the personal loan used for
don't tell me personal stuff
all right i used it to uh you know
consolidate credit card debt
do you still have those credit cards no
so i
actually i've in the past five months
i've paid down
almost fifty thousand dollars in debt
tyler i didn't ask you that i said
are those credit cards still in your
wallet
no they're they're gone i'm 100 credit
card debt free you cut them up and close
them
up close them no more all right here's
the deal i like your mindset what cause
what's causing you to get to this change
why are you shifting shifting gears now
man when i looked uh at you know i
started listening to dave looked at the
debt and it was
i think 150 160 000 yeah
you know many months ago and i said it's
it's got to stop so
um but like i say we're making a lot of
progress
i'm just i don't know if i should save
the trailer till last you know being
in the baby step program right or try
and take care of it now
okay tyler what's your household income
buddy
uh 130 000. okay you both working
no just me okay here's the mindset
around this that i look at
you know obviously i i want you to be
able to attack these and we tell people
that snowball smallest the biggest here
as you get to this fifth wheel this that
this thing's going to be a behemoth
because you had rolled in the other one
along with this okay
um and so here's here's the suggestion
i would suggest you reach out to your
bank and find out
what they might do unsecured i don't
think it's gonna work i'm a former
banker
banks love to be able to have collateral
that means they've got security
on something uh but what would they do
if you got intentional you got this
lease out of your life
right you got intentional you got this
personal loan out and if you were to
sell this thing and if it was worth 50
right now you're talking about trying to
get a 37
000 loan you can have the conversation
with them i
this may be one of them the levels of
stupid tax
where you just got to dig in and pay
this thing off like it unfortunately
because of the roll in
it's almost exactly to the dollar what
the role is what it was
exactly sell it in be scottish which is
why i we advise people and again i'm not
here to beat him up
i want him to hear it and i want other
people out there listening to understand
don't roll stuff in these car lots and
these other places
they love for you to come on in and
they'll tell you everything's going to
be okay
i want us to start to think all right
ahead so tyler you can reach out to that
bank find out
what amount they would do on a personal
loan for you odds are you're probably
going to have to just
put your chin down get get focused and
attack this thing
and that's looking for ways to bring in
extra income that's looking for ways to
really dig
in on this i like the path that you're
on and i don't want this to defeat you
this is just one of those lessons you
look at you go
if i could just go back right and you
can't we all want to
but i tell people you can glance back
but you got to focus forward baby
and that means digging in and getting
intentional and attacking it uh boy that
roll in and i'ma tell you john
this happens a lot in car loans okay car
loans big time
where they'll say hey you owe this on it
it's only worth this
here's what we'll do we'll roll this
into your new loan
and now they have nine year car loans
did you know that nine
years nine years because people don't
know how to count we only go by payment
and so they'll say hey it's just it's
just you know uh just just
you know 127 000 easy payments of 299.95
and people go it's just 299.95 they
didn't hear the 127
000 part nine years ago was four jobs in
two states ago for me
nine years i mean seriously when you sit
down and sign
nine years a decade of your life away
for a depreciating asset yep
and you willingly say i i'm gonna pay
you
ten thousand dollars more than it's
worth because you're you're doing me
such a great gift of taking the old
thing from me
well see you're you're doing the math
now you've learned that's just math
but that's not even emotion being normal
it's just a matter of the payment
and so i tell people don't live based
off payment what you have to do is we
got to learn to do the math
outright and so looking at this you know
you don't want to roll in a car loan
with another car you want to pay the car
off and drive that bad boy
but this is one of those things where
you can kind of get handcuffed yep
um and so tyler dig in talk
let's get this lease out of your life
let's get this personal loan paid off
and then begin to kind of really turn
your attention toward this fifth wheel
um and talk to the bank have a
conversation
the other option is this once you talk
to the bank if they won't do anything
check with the credit union to see but
again it's the collateralization they
want the title to this thing
uh they're not going to let it go so you
get it intentional you get it down maybe
down to 20 000
uh that's owed outright you may be able
to do that but don't do me a favor
no more consolidation okay no more
rolling things in think about it
even the word consolidation con
[Laughter]
consolidation i've never heard of that
oh yeah no it's fake
just ask yourself before you buy a car
if you're about to buy a car for 20
grand
and you owe another one and they say hey
we'll just roll the other one into it
would you have bought that car for 30
grand no because it's too expensive
that's right
it's too expensive you're not going to
go that route so i want you just to
start to think clearly
keep your eyes open and know exactly
what it is and as i tell people you want
to make two-year decisions
you want to make a decision that you
look back on in two years and you're
glad that you made it
that requires us to reach up and look
out a little bit but we can do it
i can almost guarantee you that wherever
you think you'll be in nine years
you won't be and you probably won't be
where you are right now that's a good
point we got options though
remember you're not stuck you just stop
people keep pushing and keep driving